sometimes in America you must look at
what you had and lost in the great
golden age of fast food in the late 90s
and the early 2000s when we were
comforting ourselves in the grilled
stuff burrito while watching our fellow
citizens jump out of Windows on
911 we were eating the Wendy's Monterey
ranch chicken sandwich bacon in the
ranch dressing in a gold wrapper with
Montery jack cheese eating it as we
watch cigarette smoking girl put uh
young mostly innocent uh Arabs on
leashes and walked them around Abu gra
and we were uncomfortable with that we
only took comfort in the Monterey ranch
chicken sandwich we would eat that okay
while we would watch many of our fellow
citizens lose their houses